in recent years the digital video
monopoly YouTube which is part of the
digital search monopoly google has been
accused of trying to silence
conservative viewpoints Praeger you and
other innocuous center-right content
providers have found themselves censored
on YouTube YouTube denies doing any of
this on purpose it was accidental they
say we have no political agenda what
turns out that's a lie this show has
exclusively obtained an internal YouTube
memo from April of 2017 last year that
lays out in detail how YouTube censors
videos one of the reasons the extent of
YouTube censorship isn't obvious to most
people is because the company is smart
enough not to scrub every video
it wants to censor instead many videos
wind up in what the memo describes as
limited state sounds like something out
of Scientology videos in a limited state
are intentionally pushed down on the
site so they're harder to find
they're also demonetised meaning the
people who post them can't make money
from them no matter how often they're
viewed I think that isn't a big deal
what would happen if you couldn't find
the New York Times on a newsstand what
would happen if it's publishers weren't
allowed to make money from selling it
would that qualify as censorship
obviously of course it would so what are
the criteria for censoring videos on
YouTube well according to the memo quote
controversial religious or supremacist
content qualifies so does quote highly
controversial inflammatory content
what exactly does any of that mean none
of it is defined it's totally subjective
a YouTube makes the call and does so
with maximum political intent for
example YouTube decided it was
inflammatory for Prager you to question
the notion that all cops are racist if
you don't think they are you're in
trouble according to youtube so Prager
used video was demonetized and
effectively declared hate speech
you had videos that suggest that I don't
know white people are inherently evil
remain on YouTube without any
restrictions that's clearly political
the memo makes it very clear where
YouTube censors are coming from it
explains that the company is committed
to quote the freedom to belong including
the resulting benefits of diversity and
inclusion a
okay sounds good but what exactly does
that mean again it's entirely subjective
and intentionally so at one point the
memo declares that any quote demeaning
language against a protected group may
result in a video being removed from the
site so who are these protected groups
well according to YouTube refugees are a
protected group so let's say you don't
like the fact that refugees are being
resettled in your neighborhood for
example you've assumed it was your right
as a citizen to disagree with government
policy nope not according to YouTube
they will censor your complaints about
what your government is doing and call
you a bigot in the process if you don't
like refugee resettlement policy for
example hmm well it's not surprising
that one of the trusted flaggers YouTube
has deputized a censor extremist content
is the Southern Poverty Law Center which
is itself irony of ironies an extremist
group the SPLC has a long history of
inciting hatred and division for
political ends it was the SPLC that
slandered the Family Research Council as
quote a hate group and labeled the pulse
nightclub shooting a right-wing attack
which as you know it was not the SPLC is
totally discredited and anyone who
spends five minutes reading about it
comes to that conclusion and yet YouTube
trusts the Southern Poverty Law Center
to censor your videos and that tells you
a lot we contacted YouTube for statement
on all of this and we asked whether the
company had revised its policies since
the memo was written last year the
company barely responded Aflac linked us
to a blog post written by a Google
lawyer last June in which he vowed the
company would be more aggressive in
censoring videos it doesn't like it's
worth noting that almost nobody in power
is fighting back against this censorship
here you have an American company
incubated in America by Americans under
the protection of American law and
courts which is now working to undermine
the most sacred of American rights which
is the freedom of expression yet the
Congress which is run by the way by
Republicans right now is doing precisely
nothing about this when you ask them
they mumble something unintelligible
about free markets and get back to
designing another
tax cut for companies like YouTube
meanwhile the rest of us who live here
the ones who still care about free
speech are left to fend for ourselves
the big digital monopolies demand that
we conform to their worldview and they
shut us down when we dissent they have
too much power they are a threat to this
country it is time to complain while we
still can
YouTube isn't the only politicized part
of Google in an internal memo that
written by Google revealed by James Day
Moore's lawsuit managers are told to
avoid rewarding people for following the
dominant quote white male culture of
America aspects of that culture the memo
said included the meritocracy belief in
objectivity and individual achievement
is that nobody thought were a specific
until now harming Dylan is representing
James Tama in this lawsuit she joins us
tonight it's hard to leave this is even
real tell us what the memo says yeah so
the memo basically says it's part of a
Google program for managers called
inclusive perf which is inclusive
performance and they are coached and
sometimes forced to evaluate people on
managers on the feedback they give to
their employees so this memo is about
when you give feedback to your employees
be careful not to give too positive
feedback to white people for stuff that
is white according to Google such as
merit-based performance and individual
excellence and so forth and then you
know when you're giving feedback to
people of color
you should be sensitive to the fact that
they're more likely to be in favor of
group achievement and collective values
there's some negative traits associated
with whites which is supposed to be that
they talk about you instead of to you
you know so they're backstabbing there
are these growths racial stereotypes on
both sides that are deeply offensive for
example to say that this stereotype that
whites care about meritocracy and
accomplishment is to imply that other
races don't I mean this is clearly
absurd and the the most absurd thing is
that James Dewar purportedly after the
fact was let go because of gender
stereotypes but Google perpetuates
racial stereotypes every single day in
its management its but they don't of
course hold their I don't know
programming staff to these same
standards I mean of course they demand
excellence when it comes to writing the
code that is the basis of their business
of course they should write yeah
I agree with that so what's their
response bin I mean this seems
horrifying incredibly divisive
inherently bigoted as you just pointed
out are they conceding this is real no
III don't think they get it I mean
Google is too big to fail too powerful
to be questioned and so they've been
getting away with this and in fact in
the face of our lawsuit they simply
described all criticism of their race
baiting and racial gerrymandering as all
right criticism so why are you look
you've been a Coggins you know you and I
had the same job 25 years ago you've
been a conservative your whole life your
math review 30 years ago why are
conservatives Republicans in Washington
defending this craft defending Google
why aren't they doing something about
this well I'm afraid one very crass
reason is that Google spreads the money
around both sides so members of Congress
and the Senate who have power to do
something about antitrust issues these
employ most employment violations they
don't care it's hard to get their
attention and you know Google very
carefully spreads the money around in
the media as well and in nonprofits as
well I mean they're really ubiquitous
and and everywhere and so as a result
people know which side their bread is
buttered and they're very few principled
people who say you know I want I want to
take your money Google I'm gonna
criticize you and I'm gonna be objective
about it so that's what we're running up
against here in this case now there are
a lot of Patriots who are shocked by
this I mean we've had the recent example
just this week of Google trying to seal
our lawsuit in fact they have sealed it
for a two-month period believe it or not
they called up the court and they said
you know some of our employees are being
harassed when I bring a motion to seal
this entire lawsuit and the court has
sealed it for two months so for two
months now the public is not gonna be
able to go to the Santa Clara exchange
it's not important read that so but
where's the outrage nobody seems to be
well it's on this show thank you for all
you're doing
Carmen July thank you thanks for having
me